I'm interested in the twin prime conjecture
so this is
Asking about consecutive prime numbers p 1 as the first prime which be equal to [2] and there'll be the second time
P 2 which would be equal to 3
And you can look at the gaps between the primes, so the gap between three and two...
is one, this is the only time you can possibly have two prime numbers which differ by exactly one, so the next smallest possible gap
Would be a gap of size, [two]
It's only not the case that all gaps become size 2
But the question is how many of these gaps of size two? So for example,
101 and 103 are two rather large prime numbers which differ by exactly 2. And then the twin prime conjecture
says that this having two primes which differ by exactly 2 happens infinitely often
If the twin prime conjecture is false,
At some point you go along the number line, and then all prime gaps would always be bigger than two
But we don't believe that's the case. We believe that it should be the case the twin prime conjecture is correct
So no matter how far you go along
There's always going to be some bigger primes and in fact infinitely many bigger primes that differ by
Just exactly two so you can test this on a computer
And we found pairs of primes that differ by exactly [2] with over
300,000 decimal digits and in fact they're surprisingly common that it's certainly not all the time
but if you look at the first
how far you have to go after a million to find a pair of twin primes
It's not very far. If you look after a billion, It's not very far if you look after a thousand billion
It's actually not very far until you start finding twin pines
Most primes aren't going to have the one after it been just two apart
But we still believe that you should be relatively plentiful and so far if you check on a computer this seems to be true
but whether it's really true all the way as far as you go is something that you can't check on the computer and
That's where you need to try and prove the real mathematical result
So we don't actually know how old the twin prime conjecture is
that some people have claimed that it should go all the way back to euclid and it's certainly the kind of question that the
Ancient Greeks could easily have thought about the most recent time where we've seen someone really write down the conjecture
officially was just over 100 years ago by de Polignac
But he actually conducted a rather stronger more general form of the twin prime conjecture that's a bit more complicated
It's not just gaps of size 2 but also gaps of size 4 and gaps of size six
And so there's a suspicion that the twin prime conjecture itself is rather older than that
But we know it's at least a hundred years old possibly thousands of years old. If we're still finding these things
Way way down the number line, and we know they're an infinite number of primes
This is a known thing... if they did stop
What would stop them occurring like what is... what beast out there could stop twin primes occurring?
It doesn't seem as any roadblocks of them happening forever.
This is one of the interesting and frustrating things about prime numbers,
that often it's clear what the right answer should be if you give me a simple problem
Like the twin prime conjecture, you can think about it heuristically a bit, you can check it on the computer
And you can quite quickly convince yourself that this should clearly be the right answer
And you can do it in a fairly confident way so lots of problems about prime numbers
we believe we know what the correct answer should be it's just that we don't know how to prove it and
The game is always trying to rule out there being some very bizarre conspiracy amongst prime numbers
That would mean that they would behave in a rather different way to how we believe that they should behave
So you're completely right that if the twin prime conjecture was false there'll be some
strange switch that happens at some strange point far down the number line
There's an absolutely huge breakthrough by Yitang Zhang just relatively recently in 2013
He showed that although he couldn't prove the twin prime conjecture (that two is a gap infinitely often)
And he similarly couldn't conclude that four is a gap infinitely often, he showed that either two or four or six or eight or some number
Less than 70 million has to be a gap infinitely often. So the gap wasn't 70 million
It was just somewhere between two and 17 million, but he didn't know what it was?
Right, he couldn't say which one of these came as a gap,
but he was able to show that at least one of these occurs as a gap infinitely after and 70 million might sound like a
Huge number to most people it's certainly a lot bigger than two for example
But before that we had no idea of, how we could possibly prove anything like this
That he showed that no matter how far you go down the number line
There's always these primes that get clumped bizarrely close together
Because when you start looking at really really really big prime numbers, prime numbers become quite rare
so if you're looking at numbers with billions and billions of decimal digits for example
Then suddenly the average gap will be well over a billion and if you look at even bigger ones you get even bigger gaps
So typically prime numbers will have these very big gaps
And he showed that no matter how far you go down the number line you will get these pairs that come really close together
At least compared to how they typically look I guess.
Earlier on around 2005,
there was this earlier work of Goldston Pintz and Yildirim, who came up with a new method for thinking about the twin prime conjecture
and problems closely related to it. People worked really hard to try and push
Goldston Pintz and Yildirim's ideas a little bit further
but there seemed to be this big obstacle that we kept on not being able to make progress on and
It was this problem which Yitang Zhang managed to break through, came as a complete shock to everyone
I think precisely because people had worked so hard on this
particular approach and all the experts had been completely stumped on this. so 70 million is a
Slightly arbitrary number that just comes out of the method and in fact his method really just showed some number
And he didn't try and optimize the 70 million too much. So if you take exactly his argument
But you're ever so slightly more careful with the numerical calculations
You can bring 70 million down to 30 million
And then if you tweak his arguments and rearrange things ever so slightly it's still fundamentally the same argument as what he had
But you can bring 30 million down to 20 million and so as soon as Yitang Zhang's result came out
there was this huge excitement at the result in trying to understand the result, but they also became a
Small online competition amongst
Mathematicians as to
How low can you make the gap that we knew 70 million was an upper bound, this is the first time we had a
Finite bound, but we also knew that by tweaking the arguments
You should be able to bring 70 million down to some smaller number
How low could you go just using what he had put out there and putting in the extra work?
So there was a polymath project
Which was a big online collaborative project that set up precisely to try and optimize the arguments in Zhang's work,
Now, they came up actually with quite a lot of neat ideas to make Jang's argument as efficient as possible
They were able to bring Zhang's bound of 70 million down to I think
4680.
so I'd actually been thinking about a
Completely separate approach to this bound of gaps problem before Zhang's work came out
so I was super excited that Zhang's work came out 'Cause it's fascinating to me because I was
still a phd student at the time. Excited or disappointed? Like did you feel like "Oh no I've been beaten" or were you really excited?
So I never had any belief that my ideas would lead to bound of gaps between primes in any way,
So I was just excited. I think you always super excited when you
Suddenly one of these big results comes out and you know that collectively we understand something new about prime numbers
So I was just desperate to get into the details of Zhang's work. There's always this
Intense frustrating game that you play when you do mathematics that you sort of feel that you have an idea
but you don't quite know
Exactly how it fits in and it takes a long time of fumbling around in the darkness before you really get intuition for how
What you're thinking about works... It's a huge motivation to me that this is part of the fun
It's the chase of the problem and trying to understand what's going on
So I was still completely addicted to this thing that I've been working on
And I viewed it as a side benefit that it might actually be able to help this
big collaborative project if I could sort my ideas out, but then the huge surprise to me was that actually once I managed to
Grasp a hold of this and look at things in from the right perspective
A variation on the ideas that I was thinking about
Were able to prove bound of gaps in a completely different way to Zhang's work.
This gave a completely new way of proving bound of gaps between times
so both my work and Zhang's work is very much based on the earlier work of Goldston Pintz and Yildirim
and Goldston Pintz and Yildirim used an argument that's fundamentally using a technique known as Sieve methods
They proved a great result about primes which come close together
And they said if we could prove this other technical result that isn't to do with Sieve methods
Then we'd be able to bound of gaps between primes, and so what Zhang managed to do is
Essentially proved something like what they wanted to prove and therefore use their argument to get bound of gaps between primes.
Whereas
my approach was based on their original ideas rethinking some of the way their original argument worked which meant that you didn't need such a
Strong technical input and so I could use weaker results that be known for the past 50 years or so instead
On the one hand I tend to sort of feel my way to a proof and know it's right before I
Actually write down all the details so I did have this feeling that yes, this has the feeling of being right
But at the same time I remember
Being pretty scared when I first came up with the ideas
Because you know I was going to be very much putting myself out there
And it's very important for mathematicians to really be strict with themselves to check that they've got all the details right
but you often have this internal feeling about these things and it felt like it to me.
I was really surprised, so yeah there was suddenly lots and lots of interest
I was a postdoc at the time in Montréal when this came out and suddenly I was getting invitations to fly all over
to give talks in different places in the US, so it was really exciting for me being able to
Meet all these famous mathematicians, give talks of my work suddenly everyone is very excited. I hadn't really expected this at all
I thought you know I was pleased that I'd proven a nice result
But I was more pleased because I'd finally managed to get an understanding of these things and
I had the satisfaction of the proof. I hadn't really expected there to be any
Media interest or all these people asking me to give talks and things.
So some people have called it the Maynard and Tao method
So Terry Tao was also thinking about similar ideas
He was very actively involved in leading this polymath project
And so he came up with essentially the same method at the same time
It was another bizarre coincidence that there were
There was this one proof by Yitang Zhang that came out and then both terry and I came up with
This new alternative method. So some people been calling it the Maynard Tao method. So the current state of the art, trying to optimize
All these techniques including with these new method and these new ideas is
Is that they're infinitely many pairs of primes that differ by no more than two hundred and Forty-six. We expect that every even number
between 2 and 246 occurs, it's no different, in particular we expect two
But we know there's at least one between 2 and 246
Can your method get us to two?
Unfortunately there's a
Fundamental barrier to our method get my sequel to to you so in some later work
we said that if you [a] really optimistic about how we could maybe get all the technical stages of the argument to fit together and
If you able to prove these other very strong results that were sort of strong versions of what yu tang jang managed to prove then
Maybe you can just about push our methods to get gaps of size at most six infinitely often
But we also showed that there's not going to be any small variation on
These sorts of ideas that can really get down to two so you can get close to you
But not quite all the way
there's a new idea that's needed to get all the way to the twin type of injection for sure the reason for it is that
We have these mathematical devices that are trying to detect time numbers
But they don't work perfectly there are only approximately detected prime numbers
So maybe they get it like one in ten of the time or one in
six of the time or something like that, and if you're getting like one in ten at the time
Then maybe if you're looking for primes that come close together you miss a whole load of being between primes
But you still find to that a pretty close together
So you may be missed out 10 of them
But on the tenth one you find one and there may be 10 times further apart in you love hopes
But they're still pretty close to get there no variation on these techniques even if you're really optimistic
Can ever improve your way of finding primes to one into?
Without using some extra automatic information and really a big new idea the fact that your proof has this
Trait to it that it involves approximation of things that aren't always right
Doesn't sound like what I mentioned a method proof
Is that already sounds like it's a bit hand wavy
And wishy-washy I happen to this beat one of these classic rigorous proof if it's like sometimes a bit wrong
like so this is actually a
common feature of lots of Modern mathematics that you'll maybe take inspiration from
Probability or engineering and you still have to write down the rivers mathematical proof
But you maybe think about the whole approach in a heuristic way
in a much less rigorous sense and so you might [think] about lots of randomness in your problem, and
You might be deliberately trying to
model prime numbers as random objects and
Think about them is not always being definitive and things being a bit approximate here and there
And when you write [down] your argument you have to write it down in a very rigorous way
But all the intuitive ideas for why you come up with that out one in the first place?
often taken inspiration from [Private] [sector] areas of
mathematics and science are you trying to find that breakthrough that will take us to tell you or do you feel like you've made your
Contribution, and that's gonna some come from another part of map or are you in the hand still and I would certainly still love to
Prove the Twin prime conjecture or something like that
And I do think about it on Friday afternoons and things that somehow. There's a big new idea
That's needed and at the moment collectively
I think we don't really have a
Clue for how to go about that someone needs to come up with an idea
and it's good to have these problems in the back of your mind because sometimes your subconscious just comes up with a
Good idea out of nowhere. So I like to think about it on and off
But I'm not working full time on the twin prime conjecture now just because at the moment
I don't have a plausible approach to how to get over their current bias
I still get my main motivation from the problems themselves, and I would certainly claim I
Haven't I [don't] feel terribly affected by the outside interest the reason that I want to
Understand things about prime numbers is because I'm fascinated by prime numbers
And I really want [to] get into the grips of the mathematical dirty details and do this although
[I] know that there's lots of good reasons for being interested in time
There's more generally for applications in the world Real world
And they certainly interest that it can be picked up on the popular press and things like that those aren't my personal motivation somehow
There's an inherent beauty about prime numbers
That's always what really motivates me to try and understand the mysteries of these seemingly very simple
But actually very complicated objects, but you don't get pressures
it's not like a boss will come up and say you know [James] to be really good for us if the
Number two came from here. I certainly not had anyone come
Try and get the enforces to make me bring the gap down so I've not felt any pressure myself. I can't speak for others
Which one would you most like to see solved which one would excite me the most I?
Think the Riemann hypothesis would be the first choice for most number theorists in terms of if you want a problem on prime numbers
The Riemann hypothesis just automatically proves about a million other theorem straight away, just off the bat
That's all these firms that say if we're even hypothesis to than this and so you
automatically prove a million other theorems just with this and we have this huge new understanding that even more than
The Riemann hypothesis as a result the proof and the ideas and the proof that [prove] [the] reason hypothesis
Inherently must get such a good understanding of prime numbers that will have this whole new way of looking about prime numbers
I would guess if someone was able to prove the [Riemann] hypothesis
And this whole new technique that would open up all kinds of new possibilities
So yeah, if I had to choose one, it'd be the Riemann hypothesis does the Riemann hypothesis ever get any of your brain done?
I
like to sometimes think about
Some questions connected to the Riemann hypothesis
but the Riemann hypothesis itself I feel I have no good intuitive way of even starting to how to
attack that kind of problem
But there's lots of smaller problems connected the Riemann hypothesis that are very important for Par numbers
And those are things that I'm very interested in certainly thinks about quite a lot yeah likely to find your n
You know your true love because the prime numbers are so far apart at that large end of things
So it's a pretty loveless place
You know at that end of things so you get a bigger a bigger numbers you might think there's just no way you're going to
Find your true [love]